und wir fragen sie zu hause kennen sie
diese frau nicht diese frau die kennen
sie diese frau hier finnlands
ministerpräsident in saana marin starke
frau muss man echt sagen mit 36 jahren
nur regiert sie dieses land das land das
sich ja so besonders von russland gerade
bedroht fühlt und dass gerade der
nato-beitritt also wichtige zeiten für
finnland und die regierungschefin sanaa
marien dirigiert eben dieses land und
jetzt gibt es anna marin plötzlich auch
als party politikerin ein video das
jetzt öffentlich geworden ist und eine
heftige diskussion auslöst ist das
angemessen darf eine regierungschefin so
abfeiern im hintergrund wenn sie genau
hinhören rief jemand kokain ja es gibt
drinks es ist gute stimmung bei den
marines dort ne da wird geknutscht da
wird umarmt
delphis gemacht st anna marina also das
ist finnlands ministerpräsident in
finnlands regierungschefin ganz kurz
einmal zurück nach deutschland geblieben
die szene nochmal hier ins kanzleramt
verlagert kann man sich das vorstellen
können sie sich das vorstellen zu hause
also lasst ihr news soffin am abfeiern
und finnland olaf scholz hier in diesen
szenen auf der party völlig ausgelassen
noch einen drink tanzkurs schwer
vorstellbar ist das gut so wollen müssen
wir lockerer werden valentina in
deutschland nehmen muss oder wieso sagen
ich glaube nicht dass sie selber dieses
video veröffentlicht hat das ist
aufgetaucht süße dabei sie ist dabei
definitiv hat das wahrscheinlich für
private zwecke aufgenommen hat aber
wollen dass es in deutschland so läuft
wollen wir so ich würde urlaub schweiz
nicht gerne so sehen und das kommt auch
definitiv nicht gut rüber aber ich denke
es ist auch okay wenn auch politiker mal
privat das andiskutiert
europa jetzt sei navarin die partie
ministerin
[Musik]